proposals from left-wing politicians
involves draining your healthcare to
finance the open borders that we just
discussed that's how they want to
finance it leading Democrats have
pledged to give free health care to
illegal immigrants they put foreign
citizens who break our laws and endanger
our country they put them way ahead of
American citizens like you who obey our
laws I will never allow these
politicians to steal your health care
and give it away through illegal area
they'll also deny your treatment and
everything that you need government-run
health care systems always end up
opposing rationing you see what happens
you look at Venezuela take a look at
that 15 years ago it's one of the
wealthiest countries now they don't have
food they don't have water our hospitals
are a disaster no electricity no it's
very sad and we're helping the people as
much as we can but we're watching that
whole situation beyond this we're
watching it very very carefully well
watching it very carefully drug overdose
deaths declined for the first time in
nearly three decades early data shows
that drug overdose deaths dropped 10
percent last year in the state of
Florida now think of that that's you
know we'd like to do better it's a very
very tough situation and one of the
things we're doing with the pain pills
you we can call them we're trying to
find and we're really working hard and
we're funding a lot of research to find
pain pills that aren't addictive you go
into a hospital with a broken arm you
come out you're a drug addict and we're
trying to find and we're getting closer
I think we're getting very close
actually to finding painkillers that
aren't addictive today I'll sign a
very historic executive order that does
exactly that we are making your Medicare
even better and we're not letting anyone
it will never be taken away from you
we're not letting anyone get through you
see these people on the other side these
people are crazy by the way they're
totally crazy but they want to take it
away and give you a lousy health care
it's pretty incredible you want to keep
your doctors right remember with Obama
President Obama right he said you can
keep your doctor you can keep your play
that didn't work out too well for those
people twenty eight times he said he's
trying to forget you bet never forget
okay never forget as long as I'm
president no one will lay a hand on your
Medicare benefits and that's what we're
here to do today today I'll sign a very
historic executive order that does
exactly that we are making your Medicare
even better and we're not letting anyone
it will never be taken away from you
we're not letting anyone get well you
see these people on the other side these
people are crazy by the way they're
totally crazy but they want to take it
away give you a lousy health care it's
pretty incredible you want to keep your
doctors right remember with Obama
President Obama right he said you can
keep your doctor you can keep your play
that didn't work out too well for those
people twenty-eight times he said he's
trying to forget you bet never forget
okay
never forget as long as I'm president no
one will lay a hand on your Medicare
benefits and that's what we're here to
do
[Applause]
I'll do it
[Applause]